hey everybody and welcome to an
explosive wild ride with stevo we've got
chris pontius and if you thought our
first podcast with him was epic this one
is insane and why am i sitting in front
of a bunch of portraits of elvis yeah
it's because i'm in graceland right now
on tour
and
i'm kicking off a pretty serious leg so
if you're somewhere in america you might
wanna check my tour schedule to see if
i'm going your way
and i gotta say i love everything about
being on tour except for just one thing
man
i don't have my bidet from
hellotushy.com
why is it so important to me and why do
i
name
hellotushy as my favorite sponsor of
this podcast because i'm telling you if
you've never used a bidet it will change
your life it changed my life i'm telling
you and that was with their basic
standard bidet now they've got this new
device called the tushy ace it's
a whole toilet seat to replace your
toilet seat and at the push of a button
it warms up it prepares your water to
the temperature that you prefer as soon
as you sit on it like you push the
button on a remote control that just
sticks to your wall with a magnet by the
toilet you push the button and it just
starts power cleaning your butthole with
this refreshing blast of water i'm i'm
in love with it and when i'm on the road
i miss it real bad but you don't have to
miss it ever and you can get 10
off your order at hellotushy.com
stevo that's right you got to use
slash stevo after
hellotushi.com for 10 off your order and
like i said it's going to change your
life
i swear by it i love it and i feel like
just lost without it but hey man
i'm on a rock tour and i'm in the home
of the king of rock and roll so i'm
gonna deal with it but you don't have to
now let's get into it
all right dude so
so we'll dive right in yeah enough of
this shop talk
um
how am i am i am i good like this is the
right rad
so uh here we go
ladies and gentlemen the return of chris
pontius
thanks for having me guys
was great being your van
dude i [ __ ]
wanted to make sure i was professional
and that we didn't retread over the same
subject matter that we did on your first
podcast i know so i watched the whole
first one and i was totally impressed by
it yeah it's good like it's really
[ __ ] good we talked about a lot of
things i don't think were ever covered
in interviews before like which it's
it's rad like it really is good yeah
yeah
it was really good we set the bar
impossibly [ __ ] high yeah it's
impossibly high so i mean oh my god
we're gonna have to really drop the
hammer we're gonna have to really drop
the hand yeah we have to dig deep yeah
so so where this is your first time in
this van last time was on zoom yes my
first time performing i had a big coved
beard as i called him at the time i've
trimmed myself up today i mean dude did
you did you grow a big beard during that
period i did not i've never seen you
with the baby i grew an afro
but i kept shaving i always seen you
with a mustache at one point in time
yeah you ever have a beard steve um i
never have had a beard maybe i had a
little bit of a goatee you did have a
goatee i thought you were i had a little
goatee that i grew while i was in a
psychiatric ward for three weeks you
know what i mean
crazy he's in the ward yeah like a crazy
person the doctors see the goatee
they're like oh he's not getting better
that's pretty good i have a psychiatric
word i know we both
dabbled in in some um
you know crazy behavior and and like
ended up in psychiatric um centers
like even if even briefly did you ever
deal with like a mean like nurse ratchet
type orderly
because i i have i don't remember that
but
i do remember it being pretty scary and
there were certain people in one of the
psych wards i was in who were like just
trapped and couldn't get out yeah what
it's yeah like they've been there for
for a long time how do you not get out
well because like you get you're you're
there for a psychiatric evaluation is
what a 5150 is yeah and you're
constantly being evaluated so if like
the the staff of the psychiatric ward
evaluate you and deem you unfit to be
released they just [ __ ] keep you dude
you're at their mercy were you worried
that you were never going to get out or
i was never particularly worried about
not getting up but i was stuck in there
for three weeks you know like the one
time and and and how many batteries
psychiatrists wouldn't let me out
how often are you evaluated i mean i
think it's sort of an ongoing thing it's
very pretty damn often right but yeah
there were people who were freaking the
[ __ ] out in my first psych ward
alan watts was talking about a study
they did in the university back in the
day where like they had a bunch of
college students check themselves in to
a psych ward and then try to get out and
then when they got in there they're like
no no this is a school project you don't
understand like we're trying to get out
and they're like sorry
you're in there's some like sadistic
people in in some like people smearing
[ __ ] all over the wall no there's some
people that work there too like are just
i'm not saying everyone but there's some
sadistic people that like i think they
like
the power thing yeah the power thing
like what i noticed one night in miami i
you weren't there scott fortunately me
and steve were out on the town yeah this
is the story that we taught we did we
told that story fully on the first when
you like woke up people didn't see it
you guys partied hard in my head yeah
when i woke up on the car naked but what
so when i was in whatever version of the
hospital like the psych ward or the
hospital there was this one like orderly
that was like i was like i gotta get out
of here i gotta go my hotel i have to
present at the latin music awards and
he's like you're getting a little too
excited i think someone needs a valium
and i was like no just take me back to
my hotel and i'm like yeah oh god it was
horrible like he was freak and the
policeman had to like break it up
okay i'll take a valium but i really
gotta get out of here
i was overwhelmed at that point that's
how that's what got me there
right i was more of a mixture of cocaine
that's what i always ask knoxville what
hurt most of the yeah defense test he's
always sad he always says pepper spray
and yeah i i
i've never been shot by a gun thank god
but but pepper spray is horrible like
it's so gnarly it's so gnarly after i
got pepper sprayed i told every girl
like your little taser thing like throw
that away it does nothing that's what i
tell people i know and i give girls that
i know like pepper spray in south africa
i gave everyone pepper spray i was like
yeah carry this with you and then they
go out for a walk not bring the pepper
spray get mugged and like why didn't you
have that i told you you practiced it
like because seriously it should give
you so much confidence like yeah the
good stuff you you're just shut down
with pepe so funny how like
at any time when we had
security i always got in more trouble
because we had security oh yeah like it
would give me this sense of confidence
like when we filmed uh jackass number
two in new orleans and uh
we uh had like armed security with us
right and uh i was responsible for
for uh riling up some folks who ended up
um like really badly assaulting jeff
tremaine right you shoved him i shoved
him yeah we probably told
hurricane katrina new orleans and like
crime was just going crazy and like
everything was in pretty uh
unstable shape i think they just made
like all productions have security and
i wasn't there when you initially pushed
the guy but yeah so you pushed these
guys came they were from
like
a group of people in new orleans that
they had beef with bam apparently with
cky apparently they've gotten into a
fight at like at the house of blues
during a cky show and so they heard the
jackass guys are this hotel so these
guys like show up that would never be in
this lounge and they they go i guess i
wasn't the guy goes up to knoxville and
says hey why don't you buy me a drink
you're rich [ __ ] buy me a drink and not
so says i did i got you a white russian
but i might have [ __ ] in it and then i
go up and [ __ ] shove the dude across
the whole bar into the arms of our
security dude who drags him out
and uh that that
kind of riled him up a little bit so
that'll do it
yeah later on some of the guys were at a
bar and i was with him and i went to go
get a sandwich and then shawna calls me
and was like jeff got a got a bike lock
like smashed over his head that wouldn't
happen if pontius was there huh no
you know what i would have stopped it
from happening you know yeah kept it
cool you would have disarmed him i would
have disarmed him you would have
submitted him
maybe a little late maybe maybe a little
late after he tapped i'd let it go
or whatever yeah
yeah dude
so you've moved from the heart of
hollywood i moved out to the valley to
the valley yeah i got out of there i was
over it
but um yeah so i'm stoked out here now
you had that house that you moved out of
for [ __ ] damn near 20 years
yeah so yeah i bought it like god before
wild boys i
you were buying it when uh
when jackass the movie came out that's
right because i remember at the time
when jackass the movie came out in 2002
i was like chris
we're like hot [ __ ] right now we got a
movie out you gotta [ __ ] tour the
world we gotta [ __ ] and you're like
oh well i'm like trying to like do all
this stuff with my new house i'm like
what are you [ __ ] talking about like
right now like tour the world and make
tons of money buy a bigger house
yeah so i got that house and that was
around i think it was around when i was
doing that charlie's angels thing so i
briefly i when you see that char i got
hired like to work for a week on
charlie's angels the movie full throttle
i mean dude one and that turned into
like turned into like months and so i
just would sit there with all like the
stuntmen and would just get paid for
doing nothing every they couldn't get
their act together for all like the
action scenes so i just sit there and
play guitar everyone was just getting
paid double overtime every day and it
was the best deal ever it was fun like
everyone was really cool and so yeah i
saved up a lot of money
but you were charlie's angels
charlie's angel's full throttle
that's like a sequel okay yeah
no but i was doing i was i was basically
in all these fight scenes with the stunt
men so
and i was i was supposed to be like some
sort of mobster
how did you get that roll because i
don't know why like
they just called me too it's called
conveniently like oh we got we got a job
for you i i tried out for like a s uh a
uh
a different part like that actually got
cut from the movie and then they called
me so that i never got that rule and
then they called me back and said if i
wanted to work for a week or two and
then it turned out to be months
and so like they had like the stunt team
from crouching tiger hidden dragon there
and all these crazy ropes and all this
setup and it just like they couldn't
like i don't know it was weird like they
couldn't get it organized quick enough
and the studio kept changing the script
and
and uh so we just would sit there like
then they'd be like we might film we
might film and they would go to double
overtime every day wow and and so what
you were sitting around with the stunt
men and they got you jazzed on the idea
of buying a house
no that's that job helped me buy that
house oh got you i mean like
it you certainly had it in 2002 and i
think that was a reasonably good time to
buy a house right yeah like at the time
everyone was like oh like it's stuff's
so high and then like a few months after
i bought it stuff just jacked up and
then now like when i sold it i earned a
lot of money on it and then that and
then when i bought this house like a few
months after it i bought that everything
went crazy again like so
yeah
so you're so you're doing quite well
with the real estate i'm doing all right
with the real estate yeah it's a sound
investment yeah
we man
we man bought a house in uh like right
in like marina del rey like around the
boardwalk
yeah
like uh yeah hermosa beach like right on
the beach it's a beautiful [ __ ] house
and uh
like that was like 2009 i think and then
he sold it not that long ago for over
double what he bought it for yeah
amazing it's crazy
you can probably be way more than double
on yours
yeah the nicholas canyon
it was rad did you ever have water going
through the creek there oh yeah most of
the time it would go through until like
this like multi-year drought happened
yeah but yeah it like it at least
tripled like who were your famous
neighbors there
oh pontius is definitely gonna talk
about some famous people right now and
it's definitely gonna be exciting and
you know what really gets me excited
having a huge boner yeah i said it and
you know what makes me get a huge boner
blue chew tablets why because they have
the same active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis except they only cost
a fraction of the price and they're
delicious man i'm telling you if you
ever thought it might be fun to take a
bluetooth tablet and then go to town
with a huge boner well your instincts
were right because it's a lot of fun and
man does my girl lux love it when i
creep up to her and stick out my time
and she can see the blue on there she
goes oh she just screams and then i take
her to pound town baby
yeah and now you might be thinking whoa
but don't i need a prescription to get
bluetooth tablets and yeah you do but
the good news is you don't have to go to
some awkward in-person
visit to the doctor because right at
bluechew.com you can consult with one of
their medical providers and it is fast
it is easy it is simple and the
bluetooth tablets are on their way to
you plus here's the kicker i can get you
an entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets completely for free if you just
use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com yeah dude all you have to
pay is five bucks for shipping you go to
bluechew.com
you use the promo code stevo for an
entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets you only pay five bucks for
shipping
probably the greatest deal that we've
ever had on this podcast so jump on it
and now let's get excited
down the street and uh yeah the crazy
thing was it wasn't
like um you know steve um i don't know
did you have a beef with henry henry i
didn't have a beef with him but we had
this woman this year this young lass
uh who
i mean there's no polite way to say it
she had been passed around the jackass
cast
and uh
and uh pawnees and i even shared her
at one time you know
at the same time at the same time
was that the vegetarian contest it was a
new year's day it was january 1st of
2002
okay like the jackass offices were just
opening but we had not started filming
jackass
the first movie yet
and uh
new year's day we had done like every
drug in the book the night before
mushrooms and and coke and ecstasy like
like cocaine
i mean dude it was
ridiculous it was ridiculous this was a
party with like the whole cast like
there was a party but we ended up back
in my apartment with this young lass for
your own party yeah for our own party
and the sun was up
right there it was the i had to pull out
sofa we were on the pull-out sofa in the
living room wow and this remarkable
occurrence happened
where
we both emitted
and it like if we weren't so many drugs
we weren't so many drugs it was like it
happened in slow motion
i saw our semen flying through the air
both of our siemens and atlanta
this woman at the exact same time
coming from like different
like like coming
and that was when she said i wish i had
two mouths because that was because that
would have saved her from turning her
head back and forth
oh my god yeah but uh but but this this
woman in particular
that this this this uh this lady i speak
of yes
had identified
henry rollins as a love interest
apparently like uh is she in town
visiting
apparently like she would make trips to
spend time with with him okay and uh and
and so i just thought that was like so
so fascinating and and i would try to
press her for
for information really we're both huge
rollins yeah he's black flag fans we
love rollins you're saying this night
you tried to or like you would see her
over that's why she was in town in
general yeah i think it might have been
why she's in town to was to visit him
but i don't know i can't say for sure
but i was like i remember pressing her
for information i was like so when
you're making love with him
he groans right i know he does come on
tommy he grumps
i mean i can't even confirm that they
even had a relationship but i just like
the idea is cool the idea went like my i
went crazy with it okay and uh and i
went on the howard stern show with that
young lady
okay and she was doing all kinds of
crazy stuff i remember literally took
her shirt off didn't she yeah
immediately took her shirt off and she
was rolling like she rolled a pool ball
out of her boobs like onto a light bulb
on my head breaking the light bulb like
really high level stuff
yeah
and uh and i told howard stern all about
my ideas of what i thought her
relationship with mr rollins might have
been like wow so i just assumed that mr
rollins was none too pleased with me
but later he said he never even heard
about any of it
which do you believe that i don't
believe it let me know well to complete
the story for people because i've heard
you tell this story before
when you when they did the tattoo the
offerings had two on youtube they told
me it was gonna be mickey six driving
this hummer and i was like snorting
cocaine off a picture of me and nikki
sixx
like uh waiting for my hero nikki's show
up like as if he was gonna be really
impressed that i was starting to cocaine
off a picture of him because he was
sober right i think he was sober at that
time
you were doing this at the job site
waiting for the first time i was doing
it
i was like a little boy just so excited
to meet us
i was out in the open doing cocaine for
the entire [ __ ] first movie the only
scenes that i was not on cocaine for
that whole first movie were the ones we
filmed in japan because i couldn't find
cocaine in japan
so yeah i'm just starting snoring and
coke and they end up and they say okay
dude this suv pulls up they say okay
stevo you're a [ __ ] hero nikki sixx
has arrived go up and [ __ ] and go
greet him do they not organizing him
they're just yeah
i go i go i go up to the suv and [ __ ]
henry rollins gets out and i thought oh
my god this is a big thing he's gonna
kick my ass because he hates me
but he was nice as could be yeah he's
super nice he was it was awkward though
he was sober too
he's always been sober right there he's
like a straight age guy yeah you're just
like well wait chris you guys knew so
was the prank just like oh it's not
nikki six or what we're all expecting oh
god he's gonna be so freaked out we have
another one
yeah we're so excited yeah because
you're there for that yeah
oh yeah did you think henry ross was
gonna beat him up or was that your hope
it'll be funny i didn't know what i
don't know what was gonna i didn't know
i didn't want him to get beaten up sure
if if if he did like if something really
happened if it went too far chris would
have i would
defended him
even when
[Laughter]
but it was just awkward kind of but then
henry was rad but then you know what i
did henry rollins was the [ __ ]
coolest you know what i did though like
the second night i actually like the day
after i moved into my house i had some
friends over some some girls that i was
friends with and i was like henry
rowlands lives down the street and
they're like oh my god i want to go
serenade him and this was like after
we're home from the bar like like super
late at night and so we walked down the
street with one of them's got an
acoustic guitar and she starts singing
um every rose has a storm like to his
front door like so loud and i just moved
in
and like and then like you know like we
run off you know laughing and then like
the next night i'm just walking down the
hill like and he happens to be like out
front cleaning his garage and so i run
into him stupidly i introduced myself
from jackass and he's like any i had to
have known it was me
and i and he's like are you a pa i'm
like no i'm one of the jackets yeah
jackass guys and i moved up the street
and um it was pretty obvious that it was
i was probably like involved in that
serenade but he didn't mention it
and then um and then years later like
rollins had a knoxville on his show
oh yeah what show uh i think it was
called the henry rollins show it was on
he had a podcast
no it was on oh like a tv sxm it was on
a channel some i can't remember what it
was it wasn't a very good talk show
though to be honest with you because it
seemed like maybe
he might have talked too much
ah there's no shows like that yeah
so it sounds like a podcast but but
knoxville brought up that i lived up the
street from him and he's like oh yeah i
was serenaded once or something like
that and that's all he said
but uh
so he pretends to not know he's probably
never never i never really talked to
rollins you know eight you know
i don't know 15 years he probably lived
by me here but he moved before i did one
time someone a bum set a fire across the
street from his house accidentally like
their camp was caught on fire and
everyone like ran down and watched the
fire and he was there but he didn't talk
to me like he was pretty he was really
to himself every once in a while you'd
see a young lady like like that you
could tell he was briefly dating like
like in front of his house but
other than that like it didn't seem like
he had company over very often
yeah but you guys have met
probably a lot of your heroes like in
your line of work like who's just been
the coolest
the coolest yeah
brad pitt was crazy was super cool he
did yeah brad pitt was super cool
leonardo dicaprio was super cool i've
never met him i don't think he's really
into animals and he came up to me i i i
hope i i guess i didn't tell this story
so i was at some event and um he came up
to me and i didn't know it was him and
um he asked me about like wild boys i
get from wild boys and um i talked to
him for like an hour about like and all
this animal stuff and all that and i was
like oh that guy was real cool and then
later on the night like i saw him like
going on his way home and he's with some
gnarly model girl i was like whoa that
dude has a gnarly girlfriend you didn't
know this is probably like gizelle or
something like
yeah i didn't and then next day my
friends like yeah when you were talking
to leo last night and i was like that
was leonardo dicaprio i was like whoa i
had no idea wow like i'm not very good
at knowing if people are stars like but
he was super cool what was brad pitt
like he was rad
so [ __ ] cool what year was this dude
it was 2001. yeah that was 2000. legends
of the fall [ __ ] like around that time
yeah 2001 and um
spike jones was buddies with brad pitt
and so they were like hanging out and
brad was like dude i want to be on
jackass like really like huh
and uh and so spike set it up
and and there was like a tv office that
we had and brad pitt's just just hanging
out just hanging out i remember like i
bumped a cigarette off of him
like he gave me a cigarette crazy he
smokes i was so surprised he smoked and
that movie 12 monkeys to get his
character he said he stopped smoking
cigarettes to just get really [ __ ]
antsy infinity and act like he was in a
mental ward god yeah he was super cool
like
yo go ahead like
he gave me a cigarette and right around
like right in that in that same sort of
moment
i had my skateboard
and i went to go do this super difficult
like fast plant finger flip trick and i
pulled it off
like in front of brad in front of bad
brad pitt i did my most difficult trick
and i pulled it first
time and i was just like i remember like
the first thing he said to me too he was
like hey how long did how long did it
take uh for your eyebrows to grow back
when they waxed them off wow that's
weird he's a fan
yeah he did super cool dude and so cool
you guys did you like kidnapped him for
the show and you did the monkey thing
right
we had one we did two bits one was we uh
put him in line at pink's which is this
hot dog stand that just always has the
craziest line
and uh
kidnapped him
so funny which the cops that we called
the cops ahead of time set it up with
the police okayed it with them right
yeah they said disregard they knew to
disregard calls about brad pitt being
people were freak like trying to save
brad freaking out like this one dude was
like pulling back really hard right you
know ryan kingman was there filming with
it like
like and it was god like bam was so
pissed about the monkey suit thing and
he made a good point he's like you have
brad [ __ ] pit why on earth are you
gonna put a [ __ ] monkey put him in a
monkey suit and cover his face yeah it's
like it could be anybody i got it i know
i thought he had one point what did they
do the punchline was that with the
credits when it's like um it said like
people yeah it was like brad pitt and
the monkey thing and then he takes his
the mask off and he's brad pitt oh so
when you first see his name you're like
oh that's obviously not brad pitt i
think that's anything
it was a bad idea so people were trying
to save a monkey not brad pitt no no no
monkey [ __ ] it was an extension of this
bit that i did before that where i just
ran around town like like um like
causing trouble just as a as a monkey
and i i swung on this flagpole
remember that there's a flagpole i swung
over traffic that was from this thing
that natas um did in transworld like
where uh he was swinging over like a car
do you remember that picture i i
remember a lot of nadas i don't remember
uh but i guess uh spike took that
picture and he so he knew where this
flagpole was oh it was amazing
um but um
i'm fascinated with like different
celebrities and like asking people who
the meanest one and who the coolest one
was i can i can tell you who the meanest
one i ever met oh her name is ellen
degeneres
it's crazy that all this stuff's come
out like about ellen being mean because
when i met her i thought she was really
mean like
why'd you meet her i met her at the vh1
bigano four or bigano five awards
and um it was when her show was like
i guess she was the the big thing at the
time and all the like her sitcom or her
ellen show the ellen show or the one
where she like in her yeah her talk show
she talks so she was there and um i
guess i was in the green room and there
wasn't that many people in the green
room like and um so everyone like got to
talking pretty good and like someone
like warned her that like one of the
toilets was broken because it was like
these kind of like those fancy outdoor
toilets and she was like just keep a
really rude response and then she was
just smoking cigarettes like in her
house she was smoking cigarettes yeah i
was so surprised she was smoking and
she's like so what do i got to do like
and she just pissed to be there and then
she comes out on stage and she's like
all like funny nice ellen you know like
that the person that they think she is
so i talked to her and um i she had no
interest in talking to me at all she was
like and yeah she hate i don't know she
seemed to hate me but then she seemed
just to hate everyone so i wasn't
surprised when everyone came forward
saying that ellen is a tyrant
yeah well what about working with
britney spears did you both
cool super uh she's perfectly sweet and
if anything she was just i thought
britney spears was insulated by like
people trying to keep you away from her
but like if you could get to her she's
down she's just she's really [ __ ]
super nice yeah and it was crazy because
remember there was a helicopter flying
above just because they knew that
britney spears was out there filming
really all right paparazzi helicopter
yeah that's next level that is next
level like especially like what does it
cost to get a helicopter up in the air
you know it's not a drone yeah it's a
[ __ ]
like i can tell you what yeah
to maybe get a photo it's a huge
investment what about working with kim
kardashian she was cool as hell i heard
she was nice yeah she's she's uh
super super laid back like you know i've
met kim kardashian a bunch of times yeah
i've heard i've always heard she was
really nice yeah who have you met that
wasn't so nice um lindsay lohan no
lindsay lohan was always super sweet to
me i i partied with her a lot okay i
remember hearing some of those party
stories yeah yeah lindsay lohan i
partied with her a lot one time she came
over to my apartment
and uh was a lot immediately locked
herself up in the bathroom like i with
like one of her friends
and then it turned out that
she had left her wallet
in my bathroom at my apartment so she
reached out
to try to try to get her wallet back now
meanwhile
while she was at my apartment i pulled
out a video camera on her and like just
filmed some stuff that made her like
pretty uncomfortable and uh
then the next day she's like hey i left
my wallet can you bring it to me
and uh i [ __ ]
brought her back her wallet and made her
sign a release for him
i traded her i was like yeah yeah here
you're waiting here's your wallet but
can you decide
because you were gonna use it in like
one of your own videos yeah i wanted to
use it in one of my own videos it wasn't
anything like that bad it wasn't
anything that bad but it just also was
like i just stuck a camera in her face
and it was like
i've seen the footage i think at the
time it's like she was like a paparazzi
you know it was when she was created
upon yeah so any like her partying like
for you to pull out a camera like this
is the last thing i want to see i think
that's when she started hiding in the
bathroom
and then you're like you're like lindsay
i want to show you a trick with this
knife on my nose or something like that
she just refused to come out
yeah
um did you told me a story about like
partying with her in new york and like
her having like two suvs and like
bodyguards and like muscling people out
of the bathroom so
like
yeah there's a little bit a little bit
of that i don't know if these are
private stories
um maybe yeah yeah maybe i should avoid
those yeah yeah then i'm not gonna i
well i'll say this there was uh at some
point i feel like it was in the news
that
she had like a list of
there was something that got like leaked
and it came out and it was like in her
handwriting and it was like
she had written a list of like famous
men that she had been in bed with yeah
and uh
i i
she hadn't she had mentioned some of
that i remember you telling me telling
me about asking her about them and like
who was the best and like throughout the
smallest leader she yeah she did
critique yeah
is there a best we can get or any sort
of uh
yeah i'll leave it at that fair enough
but wait to for chris's question
who was the least cool celebrity you met
oh boy we're about to say some not very
nice things about a bunch of celebrities
and i don't even feel bad about it but
you know what i do feel really bad about
is the awful garbage i have been putting
in my body my diet has gone to absolute
hell here at graceland they've got this
rocket roll cafe where i ate
fried cheese that was my best option
mozzarella sticks and oh dude so bad
but the one thing saving me is athletic
greens baby it's
just
right here
comprehensive
and convenient daily nutrition you know
what that means this gives me all the
nutrition i need it's saving me from my
terrible diet on tour okay it's got
75 different vitamins
minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics
it helps gut health it helps digestion
it helps with brain work i mean it
really helps me think better i'm telling
you i love it i swear by it i use it
every day and it is saving me from
myself and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo you'll get an entire year's supply
of immune boosting vitamin d plus five
of these comprehensive
daily nutrition packets completely for
free with your first purchase so get on
over to athleticgreens.com
stevo and get healthy yeah dude
now let's talk crap about celebrities
for me the least cool and not because
you were being like annoying or right
right right right
take all those out oh well then everyone
was pretty cool
yeah who was the who's the guy that you
got in the vegas mike ness and he or she
he was that guy he he wasn't uncool at
all i remember i mean dude like i'm
always annoying or at least i was really
annoying and i remember kid rock was
with pamela anderson and like
again there was like 2001
and i was like yo dude oh man let me
show you this trick i mean i'm just
tricking i'm like balancing the cup and
i'm trying to lay down and like he just
[ __ ] kicked me
he just straight kicked me and uh
knocked the cup off my head ruined my
trick
oh i remember like i might have been at
this party like we went to like some it
was like stuff magazine or one of those
men's magazines yeah and then after we
went to like the after party and like i
saw i remember seeing kid rock with his
chick i thought it was like this gnarly
like stripper looking girl and
once again i didn't recognize the star
it was pamela anderson yeah but i was
blown away by how like that was that was
actually where there was a santa monica
pier yeah [ __ ] stuff magazine party
that was where kid rock kicked me yeah
in the middle of my trip
in the middle of my trip well you do you
just go to people be like let me show
you a trick yeah yeah dicaprio can i
show you a trick that's what he did to
everyone not even celebrities though
when we first met him yeah oh dude i
remember like what was your go-to trick
though i balanced the cup on my head and
dropped me without touching with my hand
would
a lot of people were not [ __ ] stoked
i remember perry farrell from jane's
addiction
he was in the middle of
way before even jackass and uh and like
a crowded nightclub and he's trying to
just navigate his way through the crowd
and i'm like yeah dude
and uh and they would watch the whole
trick and be like cool and uh and prince
was super a jerk to me i remember i was
like i was like oh prince prince do you
don't let me let me show you a trick and
so i'm doing my trick and i had uh
this model girlfriend and and he turns
to my my mother girlfriend he's like
does this impress you
like you said it in a real condescending
dick way and you were famous by this
time already yeah yeah and uh and my
model girlfriend said yeah it's actually
pretty pretty impressive you should you
should check it out it's me and he was
just
but yeah but chris makes a very good
point that like like i i definitely
inspired a lot of people to be jerks to
me
perhaps perhaps you set them up
but i remember uh
one of the first or second nights we
ever hung out like we were at the hotel
that we were staying at in miami for
jackass and we were climbing on like the
balcony or something the security guy
guard like rolls up on a golf cart and
he's like hey you guys got to get down
and you're like dude it's cool and you'd
like jump down and you did like you like
did a press to handstand for him like
show that it was cool
he's like yeah you did that for me
before at a bar and i bought your drinks
you know what
i think the word might be incorrigible
for sure well we talked about when your
sister was on the show we talked about
how when your parents would have guests
over they would make you and cindy come
perform tricks for them like perform for
them that's do you think that like
that's possible
when you meet someone you want to show
them a trick that's like your go-to
instinct
and i think it could be from that it
very well could be it's that's that's
insightful i think that when i was
editing it i was like oh my god yeah
maybe that's where it comes from let me
swim 100 laps for a dollar for you
yeah it's like a new person like a new
friend like let me show you a trick let
me perform yeah what am i that's heavy
dude yeah i mean dude
and let me say too like
having watched our first episode
like i [ __ ] i'm so grateful for you
dude
i mean i just [ __ ] love you so much
man and uh particularly as we reflect on
what an annoying douche i've been over
the years like uh you are
unwavering love and support of me i love
you too and and i didn't think you were
being you were annoying i think i think
but i yeah when i said that like it was
maybe the celebrities might have taken
you as as aggressive i i like i i i can
be a lot to handle overly friendly yeah
my problem is too that what like the
more a person excites me the more
amplified my approach to them is yeah so
it's kind of like like like people
stutter when it's most important for
them to not stutter right like i'm the
biggest articulate i'm the biggest
douche when it should be important to me
to not be a douche right no but you're
like when we have something on the
podcast that you really want to have on
like you're really
like articulate you know i'm sure the
drugs and alcohol didn't help at all the
case but like when you have somebody
here like you're not overzealous or
anything like that like you just
it takes you a little bit longer to get
to the point but like you don't you
don't go crazy no yeah you're not so
much this way now the way that we're
coming away i've never known you like
that
since i've known you you know oh yeah
that you were just excited you were just
happy to be there yeah you know the
people and at least you were nice you
know the worst people are the people
not the big celebrities like brad pitt
or leonardo dicaprio it's always those
fly by night celebrities that like are
like big one day and then gone the next
that think they're like the biggest deal
in town like those are the ones like the
situation that guy wasn't he
he he was uh he was a jerk to me the
situation yep yeah would i like your
trick
awards the mtv vmas or no sorry it was
the mtv music award mtv movie awards and
we were there to promote jackass 3d
and uh like i went up to the situation
on the red carpet and you're sober i was
sober
and i went up to the situation
and uh he cool guide me i forget i
forget what that's too cool though he
snubbed you he was too cool he snubbed
me you were like i might have been i
think i might have been barging into his
interview and interrupting him
and i was making noise
i haven't seen nothing of that guy since
that comedy special like
i wasn't on that one i wasn't on the one
but he was on the roast
trump didn't he roast trump like uh
perhaps it was it was pretty gnarly it
was it was pretty gnarly bomb and uh and
and certainly he yeah he really bombed
however i'm not trying to
beat up on him too much you know i i
think uh how how were all the stars when
you did the the celebrity roast were
they all i mean pretty cool they were
super cool the um the clip of amy
schumer saying that ryan dunn joke kind
of went viral when it was like right
chris
let's be clear that
amy schumer was not uh saying anything
disparaging of ryan dunn sure her the
thing was that uh she you know there was
nothing
like wrong about what she said oh your
friend died and you know that's so sad
but like i was along with everybody else
thinking man why couldn't it have been
stevo right you know so it's like
i mean i don't know i think i think she
caught a lot of uh of grief for that
that i i don't think that well i'm not
saying we should pile under i just saw
it
you know myself i got carried away in in
all of the grief that was being thrown
at her and and i at one point reached
out to uh
you know to just try to
say hey like i was [ __ ]
i'm not proud of how i handled this
situation i was i was a jerk and i
contributed to it and uh we made
we made everything really nice and now
whenever i see amy schumer getting
griefed for that to this day just i
don't like it like i don't think she
deserves it and it bothers me good do
you guys have any cool ryan dunn stories
partying together or anything like that
think of something in particular can we
get you to squeeze a word in edgewise
i'm just i'm doing my thing where i
won't shut the [ __ ] up no no no but this
is interesting this is all this is all
cool this is great but yeah you guys
first met ryan on the first season or
not even
ryan dunn was actually like watching him
he was by far my favorite of all those
guys from pennsylvania i think
too but dico never really came out and
jackass like right right right right it
was amazing in cky but
but uh but like on jackass i thought i
just liked ryan's like personality like
first thing i ever saw him was that
backwoods crap and i was like i mean
dude how insane is it that ryan dunn
was okay with being called random hero
can you imagine like if someone tried to
give me the name random hero
how [ __ ] incensed i would be i'd be
like no like
try not to like yeah i think hopefully i
don't yeah and and and it's it's wildly
impressive that's one thing i gleaned
from listening back to lack of ego
though like oh sorry to interrupt you
lack of ego also can kind of i think
it's hurt me because to be like like an
entertainer or someone that's like
like being famous like you need some
sort of ego to a point you know like for
the sake of your career like
you got to believe in yourself like i
mean which is different than having a
big ego but you know
a lack of ego can also hurt you like i i
see i see how that works and you know
like what i was gonna say is listening
back to our first podcast together you
uh you really
like eloquently
articulated that
you're not
you know like they you are
you came into the entertainment industry
but that re you never really identified
with like the whole show business kind
of a hollywood thing and you know you
feel like
you still don't identify
that way
and um you know it's just not what makes
you tick and i think that from a career
perspective that
it does
work against you yeah it would help if i
was a little more
yeah like
shameless self-promoter yeah
maniac because yeah i just it would it
would help but you know to a point you
know because i mean every everyone like
rockstars actors they are like you know
they have egos to a point like it would
help because i was just never like i
want to be famous i know i want to be
famous and then i just became famous
like and
right but i think you it like it does
work against you too to a degree but at
the same time like you're this special
like unicorn kind of you know like like
whenever you pop up it's like it's more
it's something [ __ ] that's a nice
thing to say that's rad thank you like i
i think i think um yeah it
to be like look at you got to be look at
me to a point you know like and so i'm
trying to be better about it too yeah
but uh like and also like on jackass we
all have our role you know it i think a
good thing about jackass is like the
variety of people that we happen to just
land with like how you know it was never
meant to be like a little person a big
guy
et cetera but it just happened to be
that way but like
as like jackass went on everyone kind of
knows where they fit in and what you
know like where someone's strengths are
and i think now when you say that uh you
know you're you're gonna work on being
more like sort of uh of an attention
seeker well that's how i'm hearing it
and i like that because i've been i've
been trying to to to encourage you to to
get into creating content yeah you know
running a youtube channel putting up
videos like i really think that that is
the way to the future and it's so
creative too i mean dude you are so
creative and and when i just think of
like a chris pontius youtube channel and
like how [ __ ]
genius and just wonderful
your videos will be well
big brother you were my favorite writer
oh thanks you know and and that's
that's rad and i love writing in in but
it's like
you know everything anything that you do
creatively it's all like filming like
doing music writing it's all the same
thing it's just
what it's just like the palette that
you're doing it on but yeah i think i'm
i'm g everybody i'm gonna have my
youtube thing soon
and me and steve are gonna film the film
one very soon hopefully not long after
you see this i promise maybe steve can
we already have the theme of it steve
made it up
is it live can people go subscribe
ah it's not live yet oh is it live now
it's been
live
if you type in
youtube.com slash chris pontius you can
subscribe it's going to have a chris
pontius band like i i
it was taken that url was taken by like
some random and but they were inactive
with it so i reached out to my guy at
youtube and i was like hey here's this
inactive [ __ ] thing let's swipe it
from them
and uh and so we took it over and um and
i was like chris dude i got a present
for you and i showed him i made my man
paul made him a banner and uh we gotta
hurry up before that gets swiped for
inactivity
i promise i promise we'll have that up
we're gonna film it very soon yeah i
think it'll be sick you can even set up
the youtube thing and everything i'm
like chris here i gotta hear it i'm like
chris here's your youtube uh password
login info like it's ready to go
and uh yeah and dude like i've been so
pushy and trying to be like chris chris
it's all about content you gotta always
do it but it's just a question i think
of us getting together and [ __ ] just
banging it out yeah i promise i promise
to you and i promise to everyone though
i i i do need to do that and and you're
right it is the future doing these
things and not stuff has changed from
like making tv shows and yeah like it
definitely has changed and i've like you
know i've been talking to this person
that person about like making this tv
show and that and dude [ __ ] that dude
i've
it's banging your head against the wall
trying to sell a tv show and i think
yeah and i think even though the worth
wildness of it like even like monetarily
it's
it's that the television is
just a [ __ ]
was your first youtube video uh him
breaking a bottle over your head i put
up two at the same time on the same day
one was my uh fake condom my fake used
condom prank and the other one was
pontius uh breaking the bottle on my
head maybe you could break the bottle on
his head
that ponies is so but
pontius doesn't need to resort to
self-harm the way i do
i've never had a bottle broken over my
head break it over in your own head
yeah i mean i don't think you need that
i did i did get together with jeff
um yesterday or the day before to work
uh to work on shark week
and uh okay we uh
like i don't i had had we done shark
week when the last time we talked no
like you know like all this
that the last podcast we did was episode
29 which was just crazy it was like a
year ago dude way more dude it was it
wasn't that like the [ __ ] white hot
[ __ ] peak of the lockdown like the
initial it was 81 weeks ago so no
so we did the first shark week special
and poopies got bit it went great it was
amazing but i think i think we've
universally agreed like
not to push it with sharks anymore so
right we're trying to write ideas that
are like we want we got to follow up on
everything with poopies and and like
dude we had poopies on the podcast
and uh what a sweetheart it was just i
did i was a jerk to him like i said to
paul i was like i started the poopies
podcast and i'm like so the thing is
that you're dumb
you know anything no but you were like
so you're like really dumb
yeah i'm like see you're yeah i'm like
you're really dumb you know like and uh
i don't think that there was like um you
know
i wasn't trying to be mean i didn't have
meanness in my heart but it came off
like pretty shitty so you're broke and
dumb right
we did this twitter watch party
[Music]
i don't think you were involved with it
but it was a it was like a week ago or
something and aaron was on there and he
took some comments that i made as
offensive and i didn't mean them in his
offensive ways but he got really mad and
apparently like he left
like the twitter feed and like and dave
was on the phone with him you know dude
i'm glad that he brought this up because
as i drove over here it occurred to me
as something i wanted to to bring up i
think that that the extent to which
danger aaron has been bullied
particularly when it's off camera and
like there's not really any good reason
for it it's just like
i i wish that i could spearhead a
movement or not you know but i just wish
that danger would not be bullied so much
i wish he wouldn't also but
it's that said like i think the fault is
like having him in the position where he
can like when he he just talks for the
sake of talking like i know my role on
jackass you know like is to like a a big
part of what i do is is like
like saying funny stuff right yeah so
when we're filming and like that's i
know i'm staying there like ready to
like say funny stuff and help improve
bits he's just
jumping in front of me yelling crap that
it's not not worth hearing that's why he
makes me so mad and it's like you're all
right i don't jump in front of you while
you're getting like
you know in the middle of the cup test
and like say look at me like so that's
basically what you're doing like in
you're you're hurting the movie and
you're hurting what like my
participation and that's why it pisses
me off and it really pisses me off yeah
it does it does now now let me tell you
this um
i remember when they were assigning uh
the way that we would be broken up for
the press junket for jackass forever
and i got an email that said it's you
and pontius and danger aaron
and and i wrote back immediately i said
hey i really don't think it's a good
idea to sit pontius and danger aaron
together for hours and hours of
interviews like it's just not going to
end well because because i knew
from having spent time with danger and
you guys separately yeah
i knew
that danger aaron was at a breaking
point and i knew that you were like
they're like both of you guys and i was
ready to break someone right yeah yeah
for sure or him in particular yeah for
sure and i just i like it breaks my
heart because while there is absolute
validity to what you're saying yeah you
know like
um i just know
i'm not even gonna say
who's right or who's wrong i'm just
gonna acknowledge that he's at a
breaking point oh yeah no and i don't i
don't like making aaron i don't i
don't like to like make him feel bad and
i love aaron and we talk all the time
actually like it's when we're filming
that he makes me mad right but aaron's
rad and it's just it's it's really just
a matter of
not having him in the position to be
doing that really like right i brought
her up with danger talking about him
being bullied
really
it was a clip on our channel yeah it was
a clip on a channel that did really well
really well you know what i mean i i i'm
down for
participating in everything that that's
that's on camera and that like makes
sense and that but it's just like when
it's off camera like
i've never
i've never bullied danger
yeah like off camera i don't think i
don't feel i bully him off camera i feel
i mean if anything it's like wall
like i mean it's whenever he steps on me
talking or interrupts me or talks over
me
it's so frustrating and it so i mean it
it it hurts so funny like this is like
chris
uh expressing how i feel when i'm doing
my comedy show and people are yelling
[ __ ] out during my act that's a good
talk drives me [ __ ] nuts yeah so so
yeah does that happen a lot like when
you have to deal with a heckler yeah
every show
i got into therapy for i literally
[ __ ] went on better help and got
[ __ ] therapy because i can't
i [ __ ] can't handle it really you
already know you already talked about it
in therapy yeah i've had i've had i've
had numerous sessions did they get to
the root of it
i mean it's just like i mean basically
it was like i had to do inventory on it
you know well that's in the thing of
parting part of being a comedian is how
you how good you are dealing with with
that i actually kind of like heckler's
to a point like well i mean the word
heckler conjures up notions of wittiness
and like challenging the community yeah
but the reality of heckling is just it's
[ __ ] drunk [ __ ] that are just
yelling out with bad timing so they they
they stomp on your joke they [ __ ] oh
yeah you're in your joke it's it's it's
everything that you're describing about
danger aaron yeah but doing that during
your show yeah that's not like a heckler
in in the sense that like yeah your
stereotypical sense of it like just
challenging the comedian to a joke
contest yeah they really are messing up
your show right i had a guy actually do
that to me at a show a while back and
what i did
like you can't always do this i invited
him up on stage and then choked him out
i didn't choke him out he was a really
aggressive really drunk heckler and i
invited him up on stage and i put him
like in the corner like he like he was
going to do something and then i just
like forgot about him and i went back to
my show so he stood there like awkwardly
for like 10 minutes like looking around
like thinking he's going to get called
and then he was like
oh and he just like walked off wow
i i didn't mean it for to be smart
either it just happened like i just put
him in the corner right but then he
didn't know what to do because he all of
a sudden was on stage and but not out
being asked to do anything right like
wow that's pretty i put him in an
awkward situation right
i want to ask you two questions the the
one would be do you have a favorite
jackass bit that you've done of all time
and then do you have a favorite jackass
bit for forever i'm gonna answer for
chris and his favorite bit that he's
done of all time is the opening of the
new movie i'm pretty stoked on though
wow
i'm sure they're amazing a lot in the
press junkets but i was just i mean if
you think about it like
like the the box office performance of
jackass forever while it was successful
it was number one
like still it got [ __ ] by kovid so as
we're saying this there's probably a
great number of people who have not seen
jackass forever even though it's now
available for home
like you can get it on itunes and you
know home video and when you get the
digital home video version it comes with
like 40 minutes of extra [ __ ] which is
all awesome [ __ ] too but there's just a
lot of people that haven't seen the the
grand opening sequence of jackass
forever and it's [ __ ] awesome you
want to give them a little breakdown of
what it is a little taste oh all right
so my pants
without giving without spoiling it for
anyone you can i'll just say i'll just
do it best i can without spoiling like
what happens in it my penis is in a
monster costume and it's dressed up like
a monster so i actually have some things
i want to actually talk about the
experience of filming sure i mean i
remember on the set like you're like
you're in the middle of this big
miniature set you've been making like
this big miniature set you're underneath
and there's just all this [ __ ]
machinery and your dick got like [ __ ]
caught in like like a car like some cog
of machinery it was the gnarliest what
what machine so
they had they had like they had the the
like oscar award-winning [ __ ]
puppet puppeteer team the guys that did
the puppeteering from like ghostbusters
and like they're like the top like
demolitions people
and i'm on this cart
they had [ __ ] they they were
puppeteering his dick was a puppet yeah
and they couldn't figure out how to
attach it
you know they couldn't figure out how to
attach my dick to the thing to puppet it
off to make it stand up that way and
crazily enough my wife actually came up
with the apparatus like on you can you
even notice like at the beginning like
it's it's like standing up it's just
kind of weird you can tell someone's
pulling it and then it later on it's
like held up really good
you know she came up with like this like
weird thing that we got from the
wilderness store and like it ended up
being the perfect thing in it dude i
wish we had it the whole time we saved
the day big time
here's the thing like his his penis gets
painted green like to be like this
[ __ ] dinosaur monster you know
anything except godzilla yeah
as they call him
they've got this [ __ ] miniature city
for like the miniature shots they had
the whole paramount lot which is new
york city and they had [ __ ] huge
cranes throwing [ __ ] cars explosions
everything like it was a 3 million
dollar
gnarly and there's a slot like that that
my
my penis and my balls are going through
and i'm under the table and there's a
plat there's like a rig that it's like
on wheels or something that like like
yeah it enables me to travel under the
table so like when it's too tight like
it gets caught like your balls get
caught or whatever it's gnarly but the
thing that
i have some thoughts to share about my
whole experience i've never even
mentioned so
the first thing we did for preparing for
this bit like we actually it was first
going to be a bit and then it ended up
and we had a way scaled down version of
it but then when we started to film it
they're like oh this is too funny we got
to make this the opener but anyway so i
meet with like this makeup artist guy
we're in this like room basically
together and like he's got to paint my
dick and in all this and put all these
like at least like scales on my the like
the backbone on my dick and all these
things and it's so awkward like you
always think in the back of my what if
like i accidentally got a boner you know
and it would create this really awkward
situation because my dick's literally in
this guy's hands and like you know just
by not wanting to get a boner so bad
what if i got it made me get a bone did
you get a boner you know how that
happens when you're
don't think of a pink elephant yeah
no i didn't get a boner not even close i
was fine but then like um
like um
like but there's always that fear you
know and when you're doing it like so
you know you get talking and try to just
ignore the fact that this dude's holding
your dick and like
painting and putting like little eyes on
your dick and like and but the
awkwardness of if i accidentally did get
a boner
like video nice hands
um
no not that i remember a gentle touch
did he tickle a little bit no but how'd
the brush feel
it felt fine the thing was like after
when um
like um when my wife later on like came
to help me clean it up with some oil
because like i don't want him to have to
be the one scrubbing it then when she
was doing i almost got a boner and it
was almost embarrassing for me to get
the boner in front of even though he
wasn't the one scrubbing my wiener like
it still would have been awkward like
sure but i stopped myself from getting a
full boner
but still like you know like heavy with
blood like really heavy with blood but
like so but anyway like while filming
the bit i actually
like is
trying to be professional like is the
monsters in is like you know like
getting more and more excited going
through town like destroying the stuff i
did think in my head like to try to get
if you watch if you watch the intro
you'll notice the monster does like get
more and more excited i did do that
purposely like like i try to like i get
myself right on the edge of like a
little more excited like make the
monster a little bigger control the
blood like push a little more and more
blood into the into him to make the
monster more excited without getting a
boner because if he gets a bummer then
it then it crashes number one it's
awkward number two it's nc 17. it makes
it change yeah it changes the whole
rating of the movie if you get a boner
it's nc17 yeah you can't [ __ ] our rating
doesn't work for a hard dick but dude
like you know that perfect place you are
like right after you come for sure like
well you're not hard but like your dick
said it's absolute
best looking you aim for that you're
never going to get there because it's
too close
but you that's what you're aiming for a
lot of pressure for your dick it is
it's a mental game yeah the opening
sequence was the last thing we filmed
right oh really last thing and and the
the very last thing the with the with
the the turtle biting his dick and
knoxville sang and i'm john knox so
welcome to jackass was like the actual
last last shot and we were like way over
hours it was like [ __ ] midnight
everyone was so like this this opening
sequence
we we never even got a crew photo you
know like on from the 3d movie like they
had the whole crew in front of that big
rainbow there was no crew photo
everything went over and we were already
into extra days and they were they had
committed to this three million
dollar budget it can't go
and they had no [ __ ] idea if it was
even going to work and the fact that
they didn't know how to attack
what like on camera they didn't know
that like uh whatever you did on the day
when it was just supposed to be a bit
you didn't get too deep into the [ __ ]
logistics of it because they had no
[ __ ] idea if the whole bit was going
to work and they were committed to three
million yeah because
so because of also because of the covet
situation like all the like different
professionals involved hadn't gotten
together to have a proper powwow so the
puppeteers hadn't talked to like the set
designers and to make this whole thing
work like it wasn't really figured out
so anyway my balls are the feet of this
monster right right so my they didn't
know they couldn't make my balls sit on
top of the table so knock johnny
knoxville actually had to volunteer
but bravely volunteered himself to to
like he crawled under the table into
this tiny space to physically with his
hand hold my balls up there
so it would it could be the feet like
which is so rad that we're you know
wow i mean it's just that's that's a bro
it is a brother
to forget about like anything like that
and just realize it's just skin
and and like to do that to make it work
because that's the only way my balls
were gonna like
and right well they actually had little
baby feet that were supposed that were
like mechanically supposed to push your
balls up like uh but the feet didn't
work
so much about it didn't [ __ ] work
yeah and they're like oh my god and they
hadn't really figured it out like they
didn't know if they did they hadn't
figured out [ __ ] yeah which is
frustrating and they didn't know like
they didn't know what they were doing
and they were millions of dollars
committed to wow yeah it came out it
worked it worked out beautifully but it
was crazy like it was it was such a
gnarly set and like spike just ran that
like yeah but yeah they didn't they
didn't know if it was gonna if it was
gonna work and i'm in the most
uncomfortable position
hours and hours and hours and days and
days yeah hours
like it had to have been like [ __ ]
six hours on multiple days and you're
like squashed in this like like a
pancake in there with your back all
right they're in the most [ __ ] up
position
in order to get his dick positioned the
way it needed to be his body was in the
most awkward [ __ ] statement yeah so
they had to like elevate me into this
position and i'm like arch so you know
the highest part of me is my dude and
like all the machinery that was [ __ ]
pushing him back and forth and like
making it all work like [ __ ] it's
crazy it was like heavy machinery that
his dick was [ __ ] like you have to
like go into this zen place while
filming it yeah but you know what like
if they did you know if
if they offered to make a movie about
money and source i would i'd be the
first one to
wrap up
want to do it because yeah
maybe like like a little like i just
thought it was so funny in kid's room so
dude
you just put out these these uh ponte
asaurus skateboards and and it just it
makes me so curious
about like where
the rights
for further i mean
in that case the skateboard the person
who drew the podcast right so
of course sean cliver owns the rights to
that drawing but are there is there a
bigger
like uh is there a copyright to the idea
of pontiasaurus well what about what
about sarco shirts yeah what about that
you mean this shirt that i'm wearing
which is available at chrisponies.com
yeah
yeah what about that shirt steve i mean
it is such a high quality i love it
i love that shirt that's one of my
favorite bits that we ever filmed but
how's that with the copyright with this
one was from a picture that tremaine
took and tremaine
uh gave us his blessing yeah
he doesn't care so pontiasaurus i'm
gonna make um you know you saw the promo
squeeze toys right right we're gonna
make we're gonna make our own and
they're not we're not they're not gonna
be exact copies of that one
but like
no i i think it's my dick dressed up as
a monster like how much can you
copyright it like well what you can do
is you can clone a willie
and then you can paint that green we i i
had something come over where you to put
steve's dick in because we wanted one to
sell like oh like a mold like an
autograph steve's dick did you mold your
dick
it's a longer story but
wait we still have the mold and it's my
gift to you
you can you can clone your dick and just
paint it green and go to like a dildo
company and sell replica replicas of
your
dad i don't know
i am going to make pontiasaurus dolls
yeah so yeah for sure because people
people reach out like every day are
asking for them so right if they want
them like yeah that we're in the process
of getting them made right now good and
and uh there should be like yeah for
stress relief
yeah there should be like more ponte
asaurus merch
so yeah so the pony source dolls are
literally in the works right now i can
set you up so many people have wanted
them yeah i'll set you up with uh my
secret weapon my graphic designer i'll
even drop his name right here mike
hillier nice [ __ ] guy is epic he's
awesome that's good he did the johnny o
board what he's done he did my bees
board yeah well he had he's a crazy
illustrator and he happens that's around
a relative of mine wow yeah i'd love to
talk to him yeah so yeah so yeah like so
yeah it's if it's it's my dick dressed
up as a monster like yeah so we're
definitely and
people are like begging for them like
where can i get one like so like well
you're right yeah i mean your boards
[ __ ]
the boards sold i mean granted i didn't
have as many as i would have liked to
have had but but there are more on the
way so sean cliver drew it for his
company strangelove and he sold out he
put them up like a week before and he
sold out like i think the first day
i don't know how fast but r sold out in
30 seconds
or something like 30 seconds we were me
and i were watching like on like like on
on the shopify thing or whatever um or
on the site to see like how fast they'd
go and it was like first minute a minute
goes by and she's like they're gone like
what like
and like people were like how did it
like i had it in my cart ready to go and
it was just a matter of
right i don't know like so yeah that
just goes to show you that you need to
be following chris pontius on instagram
otherwise you're never gonna even have a
chance i was just you know god i was so
bummed
that that not everyone could get one so
yeah
where they're gonna be out soon more and
yeah i think we're gonna have to do a
third pressing too like because i mean i
know that
there's gonna be like x amount available
but i i know that we're gonna i think i
think change it up i think uh i think
change it up and do your own artwork so
you keep if you can keep more profits
because we're gonna and then you own
yeah we're definitely making another
board because yep and then yeah with
without getting too much into my deal
with sean but
what what make another board as an
apology for this one yeah
i do love the board like i love the [ __ ]
it's great it is a little wide i know
even with shipping like it's wider than
the boxes did you did you choose that
board style because that's what you used
to ride or that's what it was choose
that shape like sean king or shauna or
his partner strangelove might have
it's a real like late 80s it's it's not
the old school or the new school but of
a distinct middle school yeah it's a
whole middle school show middle school
that's what i was considering a middle
school skater yeah like it's kind of
like eighth street video era like you
are such a middle school skater like
yeah like right when blind came out yeah
which was such an important era in ski
yeah it was like
doing like tricks like stationary on
curbs oh yeah and i don't i'm i'm i'm
sure is middle school like is that term
like commonly known with the current
i know like
now with skaters like there's like
people like being like 90 skaters with
like little wheels
like in begging pants like they're like
i'm going to be a 90 skater i'm going to
be like a 70s skater well that mean when
the term new school came out it was like
distinctly when the wheels were so small
and the pants were so bad yeah that's
what new school means so yeah so so the
the middle school would absolutely be
the shape of the pontius shape
but but um yeah we're definitely doing a
different board too as well just for the
sake of being able to put out as many as
we want
not like cutting into strange love sales
how many subscribers does the youtube
channel have just just up there live i i
have no idea
because if maybe if it gets to a
thousand subscribers you'll do a video
i mean dude
we just have to open our accounts
we have to open our calendars and we got
to make a date to get together and at
that point it's not about let's
officially make a date like we'll make
it after we do this we'll make one yeah
i leave town for a little leg tomorrow
but uh but right when we get back dude
it's on where are you going thank you
you're going out on tour oh yeah that's
right i'll be uh going to what
louisville kentucky and memphis
tennessee and rutland virginia
charlestown
uh west virginia [ __ ] uh
portland maine portland maine
it's gonna be quite an exciting run i
have a question about your comedy tours
is there an area that really is you know
when comedians like are always like i
love playing here and so on which you do
like but is there an area which really
is like the funnest area to do your how
many shows
i'm not going to say that um
in the states i mean i think that like
i i enjoy
and and
i enjoy a more
sophisticated crowd that's not gonna
be disruptive yeah and like
there are there's
types of places where the wilbur in
boston
that dude super sophisticated crowd
that's like
you know perfect i definitely noticed
that too like i think because the
theater sets the mood too though like
right it does elegance definitely true
like we i did a show with some of the
jackass guys it in i couldn't even hear
myself talking it was just this gnarly
drunk belligerent crowd like right and i
was standing there just not i kind of
didn't know what to do like
right and we man was so rad like he's
good at handling hecklers like some guy
comes up with like aggressive like and
yelling stuff while he's trying to talk
we man's like can i let me see your
phone dude and he the guy hands him his
phone we man just hugs the phone into
the crowd like i was like whoa you're
aggro like that's a good way to handle
them too i mean i couldn't do it but the
guy was interrupting the show and being
rude yeah
and um jason really put him in his place
i'll tell you what he didn't do it again
yeah
yeah because it could be what was also
crazy about that same show i think that
was the show where i put the guy in the
corner that same show
so um
um dave england felt that aaron was
talking for too long and so he yanked
aaron
uh off like with a cane like off the
stage yeah gone show style preston told
me about that god so aaron was mad about
it already and i guess like the night
before dave hadn't been out in public
like away from his family in a while and
he was a little too excited dave was
like being crazy on stage like trying to
pee on like aaron or everybody else this
is the punch
uh oh yeah so yeah have we talked about
that
live on there oh you did after the after
the show after the show like during the
meet and greet everyone's like getting
their merch signed and everything and um
aaron's actually on the other side of
the merch table and just steaming yeah
he reached a breaking point yeah he
reached and dave's there like saying he
dave kept bumping on the table and um
may and him and aaron were on the other
side of table like selling merch and and
he just kept bumping aaron's merch and
aaron's game matter he keeps bumping my
merch and then finally he just slugs
haymaker dave and dave freaks out and he
starts like throwing dave's weird rabbit
dave has a weird style of punching like
he's weird like rabbit punches like
and like when all aggro and like
security like
like had to pull them apart and like
already that's on camera it's on camera
dimitri has the footage we're still
waiting for dimitri to unearth this
footage yeah that should be your first
youtube video
i know like we have so much that who won
the fight we man they got separated
immediately so i mean dave's punches
when they were he
will add up yeah
he's a volume striker he actually
knocked
the table upside down and like went for
him and the security like felt so
awkward because they were like also fans
but they had to separate these guys and
like so like we took him outside and
like like like cooled it down and then
like five minutes later like aaron's
like trying to like like apologize and
he's like trying to he's like you got to
put some ice on it dave like they say
like um
that takes like 80 of the swelling off
or the first like 10 minutes is the most
important time to ice it and like
they're like hanging out together as
bros like he got off his chest
and like but like at the time and aaron
had a big his big like that's a story
that reigns on that's an unstory that's
a story that needs to unfold it does
youtube.com slash chris pontius
and there's nothing stopping you you
make a point scott there's nothing
[ __ ] stopping
like everybody listening to this podcast
from typing in youtube.com
chris pontius and subscribing so that
they can and hit the bell
so yeah
meet and greet fight yeah yeah i think
that it should just be like the you know
the the untold story of the jackass tour
of 2015 or whatever dimitri would only
like like like get get that footage
available yeah i'll give him a call like
yeah he's got to have great stuff i mean
dude tell him that if he doesn't [ __ ]
if he doesn't unearth that footage and
produce it and hand it over that that
you will be going through your drawer
looking for the right singlet to
confront him in
and i wonder how many singlets i have
left i definitely have two i've got my
like lava camo thing lit
it's crazy how much how the singlet
flatters the male form yeah and indeed
there's only one singlet for the job and
it's called captain america
wait did we ever get favorite jackass
bit of all time
oh favorite jackass bit of all time real
quick conversation going there though
yeah yeah we got some
good side tracking
like um favorite jackass bit of all time
it changes for me all the time
like um some like
like i i was really like right right
when you asked me that i was like oh i
love the puppet show for the snake
because i just i love that bit because
it was the first that bit was the first
thing that we filmed
when we started jackass 2. and that
started to get everyone like amped up to
like and a lot of the guys hadn't seen
each other for a long time yeah so like
that was like to like kind of break the
ice so right now today that's my
favorite bit but like like it changes
for me all the time but yeah i like
taxidermy taxidermy was amazing
it's just that that's one that just
doesn't fit in
like
a lane it's just this outline
you know of like just a really [ __ ]
weird that's where knoxville takes his
quote-unquote grandma yeah and she gets
her stuff that much less there's that
much time left and so
we're trying to find uh someone to stuff
and mount her yeah yeah so awesome this
is ridiculous i guess like they had to
go to a few different tactics and they
got a quote
i don't know if that's legal but we'd do
it for 20 grand yeah
and then both of you guys one last thing
then uh do you have a favorite wild boys
bit
well
i don't know why the agory is just
popped into my mind but agora's was
pretty amazing yeah like which god
like you know we we tried to film with
the agorys i don't know if people know
that we tried to film number two and and
like the other guys were just way too
like worked up the the wild boys it
proved that while boys were far more
tolerant loving and patient than the the
the total sum of the jackass cast yeah
the agorys were like were like
they got they were they they're
cannibals or something yeah they're
these cannibal dudes like
we got great footage with them with the
wild boys the wild boys accept love and
accept everybody right
and they're going there to like just
explore cultures not force their culture
on others right so whatever everyone's
doing they go along with it so right
right when we met the agoras like they
get us they're like everybody naked
black movement baba just told us to get
naked so we got naked and he starts
putting this white stuff on us and he's
like
burning body ashes and we're like oh
dead body obviously dead body burning
ashes like so he's putting like ashes
all over our bodies and like we're
rubbing on ourselves and he just took
the liberty of rubbing all over my balls
and my wiener yeah
right like i didn't know black moon moo
baba for 10 seconds before he did that
yep and and uh the wild boys are okay
with that because we're becoming
cultured exactly
i have a question for you guys and i
don't know if this goes off topic i with
wow boys made me think of sharks and all
that when you guys went to south africa
were you afraid that of like getting
attacked by sharks the whole time
that's all we talked about
there's like only there's only three of
us in the water or like four of us and
then it was a weird you know current and
that was where mick fanning got it bit
yeah south africa is just full of shacks
and cats
i was out there surfing in the lineup
and then two people caught a wave and i
was by myself and i was like oh [ __ ] and
you can't see anywhere below and i just
puddled in yeah
the second there's two concerts
all right dude i think we gotta [ __ ]
call it man you got enough i think we
got sure
i think i talked a lot and uh
you know what i'm not gonna beat myself
up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah this is conversation behind the
scenes funny source stuff was really
good actually because i've never talked
about that oh yeah oh yeah we we got it
it was [ __ ] epic
thanks for having me to
wild ride two yeah the return
and i i can't wait for us to film my
first youtube video i mean it's coming
soon no pressure dude we're gonna
[ __ ] lock a date in the calendar
we're gonna [ __ ] no pressure uh april
27th we have a launch date for your
website
i don't also say i'm gonna be a youtube
superstar you are you could be you
already are and and and everything that
we've uh built up like with our own
audience we're just gonna like my whole
audience is clamoring for your channel
so you're just gonna get like all of
my audience
i need to put more of myself into this
world
i love it i love it dude let's do it
awesome
thanks for having me guys thank you for
being here good night everybody
yeah dude i'd say as promised that was
distinctly juicier than the first
pontius episode and uh dude not only am
i in graceland and doing a show in
memphis i'm actually headlining the
soundstage theater of graceland it's
insane i mean dude i walked over there
today it's just elvis everywhere just
like and my name's on the marquee
i'm so stoked as always thank you so
much for uh sticking around to the end
of the podcast maybe shoot pontius uh a
post like like a screenshot like i
always used to ask and let him know how
how fantastic that was maybe let him
know
uh that you would love for him to
actually get off his ass and make a
youtube channel i've been [ __ ]
i've been hounding him and hounding him
to the point where i feel bad
and and uh i think we're getting them
close to actually making videos but in
any case enough for me thank you i love
you all yeah dude